[Musik]
ich bin es wieder eure liebste baby
nachrichtenquelle und ja leute
eigentlich dieses baby thema schon
ziemlich abgehakt okay es gibt mir viele
videos darüber haben sich darüber lustig
gemacht das ist kein oder sagen wir
wissen alle bescheid ist eigentlich ist
jetzt schluss aber nicht hat heute was
erreichen ich hatte heute was erreicht
ich bin kein journalist oder so ich bin
auch nicht was weiß ich irak reporter
von der bildzeitung oder so aber mich
hat heute was erreicht das wirklich
eigentlich schon ein bisschen breaking
ist das wurde ihr zugesetzt und die
quelle will unbedingt anonym bleiben ok
deswegen kann ich euch nicht sagen von
wem es ist wer das zugeschickt hat das
weiter geschickt hat aber ich kann euch
sagen es ist eigentlich schon brisant so
wenn man darüber nachdenkt welche
personen das gemacht hat eine sache muss
ich vorweg schicken leute okay ich bin
bei diesem video nicht ganz sicher ich
weiß etwas bearbeitet ist ob das
wirklich echt ist oder so aber wir haben
auf jeden fall einige informationen zu
babys neuem song bespringen einfach rein
das video was euch jetzt zeige wo die
mir zugeschickt
das sind angeblich aufnahmen von bibi
wie sie wirklich sind also wie babys
echte stimme ist noch mal ich weiß nicht
ob die echt sind ich zeigt sich einfach
macht ihr eigenes bild film ab
[Musik]
okay das klingt die beiden heute das
klingt wirklich bescheiden wenn das baby
es echt stimme ist dann hat er auf jeden
fall irgendwann bei warner ganze arbeit
geleistet
eine andere
[Musik]
ich hoffe wirklich einfach dass diese
stimme bearbeitet und nicht babys echte
stimme ist wie sie unbearbeitet klingt
weil sonst wurden wir einfach alle so
krass hoch genommen als das kann nicht
sagen wenn irgendjemand daraus den song
gemacht hat dann möchte ich diese person
bitte treffen ich möchte mich augen zu
machen
ok ich glaube ich nun meinen song der
sky ist blue klammer auf bitbop
[Musik]
leute ich hoffe es ist für euch auch
kinder sich zwischen den pausen einlegen
weil ich kann mir das nicht am stück
durch das ist einfach too much ich meine
so der ursprüngliche song ist eigentlich
schon gut produziert so das klingt also
es ist rein akustisch gut oder ok
gemacht aber das klingt
[Musik]
richtig heftig und was wir haben
material und anderen sängern die auf
einer gesangs stufen mit baby sind die
genauso gut singen können wie sie ja
können wir es kurz einspielen
[Musik]
die leute bevor mit der zweite
weitermachen wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr
mir auf insgesamt folgen oder auf
twitter oder snap chat dazu sind alle
links und in der beschreibung ihr könnt
mein leben dabei verfolgen wie
investigatives beauty welle recherchiere
ok alles klar in für die zweite und
womit wir einmal die beschreibung von
ihrem video schauen da steht nämlich
music bei sam sommer lyrics bei sam
sommer und ein rechercheteam was aus
dreijährigen orang utans besteht hat
noch in anderen song gefunden der auch
fonds im sommer kommt und den wollte ich
einfach auch noch kurz zeigen und zwar
ist es selbstverständlich sam sommer das
pizza lied klammer auf schönes
kinderlied nochmals deutlich zu machen
dass es der der babies song geschrieben
und auch komponiert hat
[Musik]
salami käse schinken schlag das heißt
pizza ganze woche freude weil ich was
ich auf jeden fall wie ein roter faden
durch seine komposition zieht ist die
bewertung denn auch bei diesem lied
steht es 280 likes zu 870 discs okay was
ich persönlich nicht nachvollziehen kann
weil ich finde das lied ball hat okay
scheiß auf in der cloud von 50 cent
scheiß auf ohne mein team wenn ich im
club leute wie ich das machen also leute
dazu sage ich einfach gar nichts
weiteres mehr okay leute was das jetzt
auch bedeuten mag das könnt ihr euch
alle selbst denken ich habe hier aber
nur dieses lied das war nur zwei sachen
die ich unbedingt gerne zeigen wollte
dass du dem ersten video mit der stimme
ich bin mir nach wie vor nicht sicher ob
das echt ist es wurde scheinbar von
einer jahr sehr brisanten persönlichkeit
gelegt aber nie öffentlich gelegt oder
privat gelegt also das hat seinen weg
über ganz viele die ems gemacht und ist
eingeleitet und ausgekleidet und am ende
ist bei mir gesagt mach dich einfach
euer eigenes bild davon ist es echt oder
nicht schreibt und in die kommentare und
last auf jeden fall zwei likes da unten
zeigt zu sein und bis zum nächsten mal
wenn es wieder heißt am ort der